[Musique]
tout sera dumas bien ouais tu ma roue
château dans ma tête
[Musique]
oui
en fait ce spectacle il se résume en
trois mots force résilience en fait je
suis parti d'ici
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on est là on est en train
de discuter normale et de la cour vous
m'avez coupe et le zinc
c'est anormal vous aurez pu prévenir
avant moi si j'ai quand même conservé 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai souscrit une excellente mutsch
vérité voilà déjà tu crois que j'ai une
frange pas du tout jaloux mais klopp à
la gazinière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bekkat on a voulu sortir harry châble
pour les femmes voilées pour leur
permettre de faire du sport oh
les fachos ça leur a fait chauffer le
bocal il était à sa de griller leur seul
neurone
[Musique]